Another practitioner had me take something called tonka, which is supposed to support the liver.
So tonka helps support detoxification, yes.
The first time I took it, I started having muscle spasms that lasted a long time.
You sell the same product at your store. What do you think happened?
I sent in a cheek swab to test for this as well.
So what could possibly happen? Let me pull up tonka here to make sure I have all the ingredients of tonka memorized.
But so a couple of things with tonka.
So tonka has the tonka, which is torro, erso, deoxocolic acid, which is helps with liver detoxification, helps with cellular detoxification.
Could a person have a reaction to that?
Because it's kind of, honestly, it's kind of on symptoms of having muscle spasms.
Other things in here is etacetal cystine, which helps produce glutathione melatonin, which is obviously melatonin is good for producing sleep.
And it can be in high enough concentration, can be an oxidizing agent per cancer.
And it has bioactive carbon in it, which is another binder.
So tonka is used for liver, used for detoxification.
Enocinocisthene is the part mainly for liver and for cell function for it supports phase 2 detoxification pathways with glutathione.
I would say it's a reaction. I would say it's a reaction to the product could be the
tonka reaction of that. I don't think it'd be the muscle spasm would be tied to anything
about the tonka. So you could have a sensitivity to something. So I would say it's probably that.
Yeah, I mean, it's possible that it really was nothing to do with the products. It was maybe
just something else that was going on. You had a reaction to something different. I don't know,
but I typically don't recommend tonka for our cancer patients. I don't always even test for it,
because I do test for other glutecyl type products with everybody. And most people don't test well
that I have cancer. And it has to do with that oxidative stress component that we talked about multiple
times. So, but I will definitely test that for you again. The only other thing about the Dutch test
people told me was the corsetin, which is in my greens. So I just said that I will take that and
develop it. Okay, that sounds good. I don't think there's enough corsetin in your greens to make a
difference. It's it's not that high of a dose. But I think that's fine. I think it's you want to get
it as great a test as possible. I think that's just fine. It's not something you need on a daily
basis any home.